when a
commentator says this it is what it is
when a writer says it it is what it is
when a leader
of a superpower says this you have to
actually
you know consider what he's saying
vladimir putin ally warns london
well bomb will be bombed first if world
war three were to break out it's one of
his allies that says this
uh london will be the first strategic
nato target to hit
by russian missiles should a third world
war erupt a close ally vladimir putin
has claimed speaking on the russian
state tv
andrei guroloyov on an mp who sits on
moscow defense committee described how
possible full-scale invasion nato
ballistic baltic state members would
work
he a former military commander member of
the pro-putin united russia party said
will destroy the entire group of the
enemy space
satellites during the first air
operation
no one will care if they are american or
british we would see them all as nato
second
will migrate the entire system of
anti-missile defense everywhere and a
hundred percent
third will certainly won't start
from warsaw paris or berlin
the first to be hit will be london
how much credence should we give to this
i i think that's political parking uh
look at their the russian army's
performance in ukraine
they've had their asses handed to them
these they were bringing in these young
untrained
well you know not well-prepared
individuals and it's been a massacre
you know the might of the of the soviet
union is part of the illusion just like
the statistics of putin's popularity
when you control the media look what's
happening in this country when you
control the media you control the minds
of a lot of people or at least what
you're projecting out there
so what are you saying i i in in my
particular case i'm a cuban born i lived
under communism i saw what communism did
to my country i fought it in nicaragua
i founded five different incarnations
so i am a rabbit anti-communist
and if we have an opportunity
to
really hurt the russians right now i
think that it's worth the money i agree
that ukraine is not the cleanest slate
well neither was afghanistan you was
iraq how many with all the wars that we
have spent and by the way guys
both my kids are military
one of them has two combat tours and i
have been in harm's way so this is this
is all like it should be i think a
personal thing i saw what communism is i
know that it is they have the goal of
destroying this country from within
from within they don't need to attack us
they're attacking us through the media
and all this undermining that they're
doing let me ask you what do you think
about yuri besmanov
i don't know okay because if you're
going that angle maybe i thought you
were going that angle go ahead roger
what do you think well i certainly share
his anti-communism uh but the chinese
communists are far bigger threat to our
absolutely uh than the russians and the
one thing the ukraine conflict has done
is to push the russians and the chinese
together
they have had a historical distrust of
each other they share a common border
richard nixon got us a strategic arms
limitation agreement out of the russians
by playing them off against the chinese
so but uh to the extent that uh
that the russians have economic problems
they have a very wealthy neighbor
willing to prop them up and they can
deng xiaoping keeps sending that signal
so i i also don't think that the war is
going swimmingly for the ukraines
ukrainians i think we're getting a lot
of war propaganda and it appears to me
that there are atrocities on both sides
the azoff brigade
he's got all wars
in all wars well and that's the most
important part right there is what
rogers has said is that
russia's economy is smaller than south
korea's and and to date this is reuters
june 27th uh the ruble is still the
strong the world's strongest uh currency
against the dollar the russian economy
has not tanked like people expected it
to it's still smaller than south korea
but
what roger said we're pushing vladimir
putin into the arms of xi jinping xi
jinping is the threat we're sending 50
billion dollars to ukraine we're sending
missile systems we're sending 100 000
troops we're not going to be able to
defend ourselves in a couple months with
the strongest nuclear power on the face
of the earth why are we worried about
russia yes i agree with an
anti-communist stance but again russia
isn't what we should be worried about
what happens three steps down the road
when china makes a move on taiwan when
china eventually makes a move on japan
they're building islands in the south
china china sea to use as airports like
they're they're making serious moves and
we're off concerned with vladimir putin
who's i mean he's a he's a bully he's
nothing more than a bully but when you
when you when you remove the sanctions
against the iranians you're sending a
signal to the chinese that we won't
stand up
so i mean when when your foreign policy
exudes weakness it's an open invitation
for the chinese to move on taiwan it's
it's an invitation for the world i mean
you've heard the comparison of biden
with uh
um
jimmy carter jimmy carter uh jimmy
carter was at least a very decent moral
man and not a corrupt man he was a very
naive man
but what happened as soon as he took
over
russia takes over afghanistan
the iranian hostage crisis we had people
there for 444 days
give away the panel
my canal which is a huge strategic
mistake
but what happened when reagan came in
as soon as he swore in
the hostages were released
so
i i totally agree with you we need to
have leadership and that was one of the
beauties about trump
you don't mess with trump
because he is going to come at you so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]